sería la principal consecuencia de la
quiebra de este gigante inmobiliario a
nivel local y su repercusión en los
mercados internacionales
por supuesto muchas gracias en cuanto a
la repercusión netamente en el
continente y en un país como china
cuando vemos que fue el único país que
creció el año anterior algo así como 3.2
por ciento y además esta empresa del
oriente que acumula más o menos el 2%
del producto interno bruto y que además
se ha hecho y que hoy por hoy llegaría a
los 25 años de edad sería muy relevante
porque la cantidad inmensa de personas
que han apostado sus sueños y su dinero
a formar parte de la misma con estos
proyectos de finca raíz además de esto
es importante decir que es una compañía
que tiene muchas líneas de negocio hasta
en el entretenimiento o en los deportes
y por ende establece en riesgo
muchísimas áreas de la vida china y a
nivel internacional venimos desde hace
varios años de la guerra comercial con
china hemos tenido unos colapsos fuertes
como el año 2008 y varias voces han
llegado a anunciar que podría ser de
nuevo una caída económica similar
américa latina también estaría bastante
perjudica
por economías como brasil como perú o
como chile que son grandes vendedores de
materias primas de esta nación y de
beijing e comunicó a los gobiernos
locales que se preparen para la posible
tormenta y recibieron instrucciones de
intervenir sólo en el último momento
cuál es su lectura de esta noticia
sí es muy interesante porque también le
permite al gobierno central de china
porque resulta que también hay muchos
inversores que pertenecen a lo que
llamamos nosotros los barones de hong
kong y hemos sabido que en los últimos
años esa relación compleja entre hong
kong y china la ley nacional única y
demás pues son son fenómenos también de
presión que puede hacer china desde el
punto de vista financiero y para hasta
el último momento como bien lo dice esta
noticia evitar este colapso económico
mire mucho se ha dicho además desde que
beijing no podría intervenir en la
quiebra de evergrande es esto probable y
de darse una quiebra de esta empresa qué
pasaría con los miles de compradores de
casas que aún esperan su inmueble
así es según lo que se ha manifestado
desde el gobierno central la principal
medida estaría en evitar seguir unos
despidos masivos con el fin de que
obviamente esto no afecte económicamente
de forma masiva a lo que es el país de
igual manera también china está jugando
mucho con el tema de dejar como de
llamarse de la fábrica del mundo a ser
un mercado más interno y que sus propios
consumidores como que soporten la
economía sin embargo por supuesto es un
golpe muy fuerte la confiabilidad y una
deuda de más o menos 507 mil millones de
dólares es bastante considerable
y para finalizar quería preguntarle para
contexto de nuestros televidentes cuáles
son los motivos de este
sobreendeudamiento del sector
inmobiliario chino y cómo como han sido
la intervención gubernamental hasta
ahora
así es qué sucede en los años 90 fue una
época de muchísimo auge porque chile
empezó a acercarse a diferentes regiones
del planeta y se dio un boom
inmobiliario hoy por hoy por ejemplo en
ciudades como shanghai se está hablando
de la compra de una segunda propiedad y
eso conlleva mucho a unos desafíos
bastante grandes por ejemplo en el
ámbito inmobiliario hay entonces en ese
sentido una necesidad de expandirse
comercialmente y hay también mucha
especulación y siempre la especulación
financiera se traduce como todas estas
burbujas y que ya vemos que también
julián kant el dueño de la compañía ha
sido como lo que llamarían llamaríamos
un consentido del régimen también ha
recibido bastante ayuda y apoyo pero su
fortuna también se ha visto bastante
menguada de pasar de ser el año anterior
uno de los hombres más ricos de asia con
cerca de 42 mil millones y con esta
caída financiera la compañía menos de 16
mil millones de dólares entonces hay un
problema en todo auge y en todo punto de
vista